here is one way to to begin to talk
about what the pandemic the post 2020
World began to set in
motion all together for a time we felt
for the ground beneath our
feet we remembered that the ground
beneath our feet is never as solid as we
believe it to be
we
remembered that
Civilization revolves around something
so tender as bodies breathing in
proximity to other
bodies we
softened
chasms became un
unseeable between the ways we've been
living and our deepest longings for all
of our children children and the highest
potentials for human
flourishing so how to step into what we
have been given to see how we have been
given to learn and to
grow I've been looking back across my 20
years of listening to the world and
being in a radio and podcast
conversation with wise and graceful
lives and I want to share with you
three Arts of living that have
persistently emerged
callings each of them carries practices
towards what it might mean for each of
us to
participate as we move forward in the
remaking of this
world the first is to see the generative
story The generative Narrative of our
time we we are fluent in and very
familiar with The Narrative of
catastrophe and dysfunction and
disarray and that is real but it's not
the whole story of
us there is also an abundant reality of
things going right at any given
time of learning and growth that are
happening of evolution and
breakthrough one of the things that
happens when I use this phrase the
generative narrative and people hear it
for the first time is sometimes they'll
say well give me an
example and I say just look around
you even when we leave this special
place and go back to all the places we
came from it is
ordinary that all kinds of people with
all kinds of lies are finding ways to be
of
service they are standing before a world
in
pain they are working with forms that
are broken they're probably working in
institutions that don't quite make sense
anymore and they're having having an
edifying effect on the people around
them becoming healers and social
creatives in so many
forms now we are strange creatures and
this is one of our strangest
qualities we don't know how to tell this
generative story of us as vividly we
don't know how to take it as seriously
as that story of
rupture and this has started to make
sense as we are able to peer more
intricately inside our brains and bodies
it turns out that our brains are
exquisitly designed to keep us safe and
on the alert for danger our brains are
riveted by what goes wrong they are
looking in every instant for what will
go wrong next and this underlying
orientation turns up in our most
sophisticated places certainly in the
field of Journalism in which I trained
it turns out that we actually have to
more actively consciously Orient
ourselves if we want to attend to and
get riveted by what is good and
Redemptive the invitation here is to
take in the
good and just naming calling it out that
there is a generative story of our time
that you can see it too this is a way to
begin take in the good let it start to
actively shape the whole picture of the
world you are working with and when you
do that you begin to make the generative
this whole landscape of generative
people and projects more visible and
defining to themselves and to this world
which carries so much pain and so much
promise my second offering is to live
the
questions and this one is a gift from
the poet rer Maria RKA who became a
friend across time and space to me in
years I spent as a very young journalist
in divided Cold War Berlin
in the early 20th century RKA wrote a
wonderful series of letters to a young
poet in which he
counseled be patient with all that is
unresolved in your heart he said try to
love the questions themselves as though
they were locked rooms or books written
in a very foreign
language he said don't try to reach for
the answers which could not be given to
you now because you would not be able to
live them the point is to live
everything live the questions now then
perhaps someday far in the future you
will gradually without even noticing
noticing it live your way into the
answers like us RKA was a citizen of a
young century with spectacular
potentials for creating and
destroying and it's come to seem to
me that the great challenges all of the
great challenges before our young
Century on some level are vast aching
open
questions all of our challenges
ecological racial economic spiritual
political fast aching open questions for
which we will not have anything like
answers anytime
soon so I find myself returned a new to
this
wisdom that when we find ourselves in
situation we are called to honor and
dwell with the questions
themselves now we live in a culture that
is in love with the form of words that
is an answer an
opinion and we are in love with the way
with words that is an
argument but a question is a mighty form
of
words as an interviewer I know that
questions elicit answers in their
likeness answers rise or fall to the
questions they meet
and it is a deep deep truth in science
as in life that at any given moment we
are being shaped as much by the
questions we're carrying as by the
answers we have it in us to
give those moments when a new question
Rises up in US stops us in our
tracks those are pivot Points those are
moments when the possibility of
Discovery breaks
in so the invitation here is to engage
the adventure of a new reverence for the
questions that are alive in you the
questions that are alive in the world
around
you that
question which I believe almost every
one of us standing before our world and
its pain and its
problems
wondering how can I possibly make a
difference how to
begin spend some time formulating your
variation on that question write it down
commit to having it over your shoulder
in your ear As you move through the next
few months of your
life see what it invites you to see see
and to move
towards and to move away
from I have found that if you are
faithful to living a
question that question will be faithful
back to
you and my third offering is about
calling and
wholeness the Latin word for calling
vukari is the root of our word and
English
vocation and in the world in which I was
born vocation was very narrowly equated
with work and job
title but we are not called merely to be
professional
people we are called to be friends
neighbors family
citizens lovers of the
world and just as there are callings for
a life there are callings for our
time it has come to seem to me that our
generation in time our generation of our
species is called to nothing less than
wholeness that we have it in us to
figure out what it would mean to
cultivate whole human beings with whole
institutions living in whole
societies the invitation here is to turn
your powerful reality shifting
imagination your intelligence your
energy your will towards the possibility
of
wholeness how to live into
that and I want to be very clear that
becoming whole has nothing to do with
aspiring to Perfection it is not about
achieving Perfection and it also
becoming whole does not mean that we
become less strange or wild or
complicated becoming whole would mean
that we Orient
together away from what is death
dealing and towards what is
lifegiving
every fracture of our world not
withstanding the science of our age is
revealing all of life in its insistence
on
wholeness the interplay between our
bodies the natural world the lives we
make the worlds we
create and every dilemma around our
techn Technologies not
withstanding our technologies have given
us for the first time in the history of
our species the tools to think and act
as a
species take that
in it is the calling of callings to make
that more Vivid and tangible and
real each of us starting inside
ourselves and with the lives we've been
given and across my life of
conversation I have
learned that wisdom and wholeness emerge
in moments precisely like ours though
ours is r
large where human beings have to hold
seemingly opposing realities in a
creative tension and
interplay power and
Frailty birth and death pain and
hope mystery and conviction Brokenness
and
Beauty calm and
fierceness mine and
yours let's
begin thank
you